Oh
ready Oh action bro camera died on the
set my name is Emma Marie and I'm 24
years old I'm 30 years old and I've
hidden around Hobart
my name's Anne I'm 55 let me give you
some snow I work I did California
Academy of Science X near codex Park I
do dirt tickets my ears organ is all
from it's called Hanson I'm Bridgette I
was there for 17 years I've been on the
estrogen and I grew up I am helping
people in the house I was hoping to work
in a pediatric hospital I only do
inpatient care because I will do care by
the help of kids
Logan was actually born five weeks early
and when he was born we were told the
night after he was born that he was
showing soft signs and my husband Rodger
and I did not know what that meant when
we were told the doctor that told us was
in tears and I was actually glad that my
son was going to live and that he was
going to be okay
during our first year we also learned
that James had an intestinal issue it
would she had to have surgery a week
after he had open-heart surgery
I really think though that I was in
denial for a long time it took me quite
a few months to really realize that um
Logan truly he's meeting as milestones a
little later and being a new mother it's
tough enough but having a child who has
a different diagnosis than many other
children makes it a lot harder to
connect with people sometimes but it's
just been such an amazing year but
jennifer is just a little nice she's the
beautiful lady
I like the big couple we are a long time
about six years six years we are gauged
I just bought it
Doreen and cause of 40 bucks he kind
loving right my favorite always like you
wanna marry me someday so I've actually
I think that I my mom is that she I
figured out the best smiles
and chip I says I'll go shopping with
you I will do not laugh with you
I love being with you also everything
that I know about my mom was so
beautiful I'm pretty me
we're really proud of you yeah dad was
actually saying dad was saying I think
she's going in for the inch side shop
that's what he was saying I showed her
he said I I taught her that move dadless
Hey so my hopes and dreams for Logan is
like any other parent we would just like
him to accomplish whatever he wants to
do with his life we want him to be as
independent as possible as long as he's
happy and living a good healthy life
then we're happy to have supposed to
respect it be honest with Dan you can do
anything Hanna yeah do anything and I
just want you to be so happy that's all
I ever wanted was for you to be happy I
would like to be crisper and empty
goodbye and determination I know that
you're gonna go out there and conquer
the world huh
you